tell us a bit about
again project management as a discipline
and as a career field
absolutely yeah there's so much to this
particular space
um so right off the bat it is a very
Universal very transferable skill set so
it doesn't matter what industry you work
in what size of organization you're part
of project management is going to be a
really important way in which
organizations structure the work to
deliver on the outcomes that they need
so what makes it also particularly
exciting in this space is you get access
to so many different tools and
Frameworks and you really engage and
involved in the things that are going to
help organizations make those moves to
become bigger more effective more
efficient so it's a really exciting
domain to be in it's one that is in
constant high demand I don't have to
look too far to see job opportunities in
the project management space if you're
in LinkedIn or dice or Monster and any
of the big job services boards you'll
see project management is always the one
of the biggest areas in which employers
are looking for people and and it's a
great place to kind of engage within an
organization and see your career grow
and these initiatives are really
important and as organizations kind of
invest in these large projects they're
going to help them progress and improve
oftentimes as a project manager you're
working with senior leaders senior
Executives you're very close to the
Strategic decisions that the
organizations are making so it's a it's
a great place for a career lots of
opportunities it's very transferable you
can move into different companies
different Industries quite easily and
it's the type of skill set that's always
going to be in demand thank you
um yeah it's interesting that
project management
of course bleeds into everything else
companies do because almost everything
has to be managed in a project fashion
but even operationally
um the principles of modern project
management have
started to affect things like for
example devops where software
development and deployment
is now
functionally
merged with techniques of agile and
scrum and that type of thing so can you
talk about uh you know how the how these
functions
work in uh
in pretty much every aspect of an
organization yeah absolutely
um you know one of the the key skills
you'll learn in this space is developing
a project plan and uh the two questions
project managers are always asked is how
much will it cost how long will it take
so project plan is a really important
tool to help answer that question as you
pointed out it's a very extensible uh
you'll be able to use techniques like
building out project plans not just for
large complex projects operational
domains uh because you use it for
cleaning your garage and just sort of
organizing things in your personal life
so uh this whole area is going to really
give you some great tools to think about
how do I structure work what outcomes am
I trying to get to
what kind of deliverables are required
how do I bring the right people in how
do we recruit those staff that we need
uh the skill sets and the capacity to
deliver successfully against this
project
um one of the interesting things about
project management is although there is
oftentimes a lot of science a lot of
structure behind it it's actually also a
domain that requires a lot of personal
skills interpersonal skills you're going
to be working closely with people you're
going to be communicating these outcomes
getting the team aligned on that
engaging with the team motivating them
so there's a lot of people Dynamic that
comes into the project management space
um you heard the conversation about
agile or more traditional project
management so you're gonna have to make
some decisions about how much agility
can I plug into this depending on the
domain and the governance requirements
how do we kind of work through different
phases of a project how do we get team
members assigned with tasks and make
sure that those tasks are helping us
deliver the the value that the Project's
identified and then ultimately you're
going to be answering to working with
senior executive management upper
management uh not uncommon for the CEO
of the company to take an interest in a
project because these are the things are
going to help change and transform the
organization so you get lots of great
opportunity to kind of get visibility to
upper management and that
decision-making process great
um so
in order to Be an Effective project
manager you have to have a basically a
toolkit that you can dip into so can you
tell us about some of the tools here and
that's a that's a great metaphor really
a tool kit and and I kind of like
thinking about uh these skills as a
toolkit you're going to reach into
depending on the settings so things like
your PMP that stands for your project
management professional certification
this is a globally recognized
certification offered by the project
management Institute
um that's going to teach you a lot of
the fundamentals around effective
project management we've heard about
agile agile as sort of a set of Concepts
and behaviors ways in which we engage
people and focus on collaboration and
interaction and delivering value in
small increments techniques like agile
scrum which is a set of practices we can
apply to make agile effective risk
management so important in this domain
we really need to understand what are
the risks exposures that might impact
things like our budget our schedule our
scope our good project managers are
always on the lookout for risk and
making sure risks are being actively
managed you've seen lean Six Sigma one
of the things that lean Six Sigma is
going to help us with in the project
management space is how do we reduce
waste how do we really focus on becoming
efficient making sure that our processes
are working well you'll learn about
tools like Microsoft Project which is a
very robust and industry-leading tool
used in most project management settings
to help you manage your your project and
your schedule we'll hear about project
management offices that help enable the
project management discipline and then
we'll really focus on customer-centric
digital transformation how do we shift
organizations from a lot of these manual
processes to more of those automated
mechanisms you mentioned devops that's
such an important part of getting an
organization moved into a digital
transformation space
yeah it's a
exciting Field in
it's a field that as Brian pointed out
will help you no matter what
uh functional Department you happen to
be in I mean these skills are important
and this is why I presume that
everyone's here today so let me ask this
poll question why have you not
uh up-to-date engaged in a program of
this type why have you not taken or
enrolled in
something like this comprehensive
postgraduate program so is it because
you can't find a suitable program that
has the full curriculum and the full set
of tools that Brian described is it
because
you don't have confidence that you get
practical experience that would able
you'd be able to demonstrate your skills
after the program
is it because the learning methods that
you've seen don't seem like they'd be
effective for you or is it because you
can't find the time in your schedule
leave this open for another five seconds
get your answers in and we'll close in
four
three
to
one
oh
share with you the result of the poll
so
the primary factors people have talked
about are getting the Practical
experience that they can use to
demonstrate the new skills finding time
in their schedule and then making sure
that they've got a comprehensive
curriculum that will actually cover what
they need to learn so
let's
talk about this program and what it does
for you so this is the postgraduate
program in project management
it is a six month completely online
program offered by the University of
Massachusetts and Amherst and I've
mentioned simply learn is the delivery
partner for this program
so we built the
early management system platform that
you'll be using fully online of
everything you do will be done through
that platform and Brian will be taking
us on a tour of it
we'll describe the comprehensive
curriculum and what it covers
um
this is designed
to be aligned to the needs of Industries
so it's teaching you skills that you can
apply directly in your work in your
current job or in any future job that
you apply for
and supported by integrated case studies
and projects so that you do in the
online environment along with your live
virtual classes that you take every week
where you interact live with your
instructor and your classmates
get answers from them get
chances to answer their questions of you
and in the time between the the live
virtual classes you have 24x7 access to
the platform so projects your prep work
on your schedule in the time that you
have available whether that's
during your lunch hour whether that's in
the evenings or maybe even late at night
happen to be a night owl so I would
probably be doing
a lot of my work at 2 A.M and you can be
confident that even if you're doing that
you have access to support tools the
support Community feature and the 24x7
help desk so
uh
excuse me I went backward going forward
what you receive at the end of the six
months you receive your certificate from
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
which certifies that you have completed
the program successfully and that you
have the skills that were taught in the
program you'll be able to back that up
with your portfolio of project work done
be able to show off your actual
practical experience that you gained
during the program including a Capstone
project which uh talk about a little bit
more later
you also receive if you are in the
process of any formal certifications
from certification bodies you'll receive
146 pdus in 35 contact hours that you
can use
for your certification verification and
then you'll also become
a member of the University of
Massachusetts Amherst Alumni Association
which will allow you to network with
other graduates and similar programs
from UMass
and that's a great
career tool and we'll also talk about
what
simple learn offers in terms of career
and job assist support
few minutes
the University of Amherst is one of the
Premier public universities in the
United States and it has
one of the older schools of management
founded right after World War II
and it
as we've mentioned offers you
certificates Alumni Association
membership
having this on your CV will be
recognized the University of
Massachusetts has a great reputation and
it isn't a premier learning institution
so I'm sorry
my mouse wheel goes the wrong way
sometimes
um
it is a premier institution as I
mentioned and we're very proud to be
their partner
so let's talk about the eligibility and
prerequisites
you need to have a bachelor's degree as
this is a postgraduate program
you need to have a minimum of five years
of work experience
uh so this is not for people who are
freshly out of college but it's for
people who have been working in Industry
um that's important for some of the
project management certifications as
well
but you do not have to have a
programming background to be able to do
some work there um will it help you with
anything you need to learn in order to
be able to use the computer Tools
digital tools for this program
at this point let's ask how much
experience our audience members do have
Cole
and while you're answering the poll I'm
going to check on
the live stream issue so
let me launch this poll
and I'll be right back
and I am back
let me end the poll here
and let me share the result with you and
almost three quarters of our audience
are people who have more than five years
of experience in work and
that's great these this is uh the target
audience for this program if you're in
one of the other categories this is
something you probably want to keep in
mind for the future
and you can contact us about other uh
training programs that we have that you
might be ready to take
for this program this is a LED three
quarters of our audiences is uh able to
to do that
so let me move on sorry about that we're
going to allow um Brian to talk more
here and we're setting this up so you
can take you on a tour of the learning
management system but first let's talk
about the curriculum Brian can you
describe
how these modules are organized and
help people navigate through them you
bet you bet so
um you know it's interesting when I was
looking at some of the feedback that uh
people are offering what's what's been
preventing them from moving forward into
the space part of it was that
comprehensive uh curriculum and I will
say as a person spending the cement for
uh for many many years and decades uh
yeah I think one of the big advantages
of this
um offering provides is that it is a
very comprehensive curriculum uh now I
know it is a it's a it's a big
investment in time it's six months but
part of that is because you're learning
so much a lot of deep thought has gone
into how to structure this in a way in
which you're progressively building on a
foundation and you can see right off the
bat
um this program starts with getting
people very well established with the
PMP that's the project management
professional certification thinking that
as the the real foundation for
everything associated with project
management so we want to make sure
people are really familiar that really
comfortable with that once they are it
opens up a path to start talking about
some of these agile Concepts and I can
tell you just from experience in the
industry right now every organization
around the world is actively pursuing
agile transformation initiatives that's
because organizations really see the
value and the benefit of delivering work
in more of an agile delivery Cadence so
we want to make sure you're very well
grounded in those fundamentals then we
start shifting into some of the tooling
that you're going to need to enable
these ideas and that's where Microsoft
Project 2019 comes in that of course is
uh not just the the latest version of
this product but Microsoft Project is
also
recognized as sort of the leading
industry standard for managing projects
it can be used for managing small
initiatives maybe internal projects with
an organization do very very large scale
initiatives so it's got lots of
flexibility it's a very powerful tool
and it builds on those Concepts that
you've learned then we move into how do
we Implement a project management office
we want to position
participants in the program so if they
need to they can go into an organization
and help us establish a project
management office that talks about how
do we effectively deliver projects how
do we track project success how do we
enable our projects and then finally
everything comes together with this
project management Capstone project and
just like the name suggests this is the
point in which you take all the
knowledge that you've learned through
all those other areas and you apply it
to a real world case study and this case
study is something you're going to spend
a fair amount of time developing it
could be something you're going to get a
lot of support from your your
instructors and even the uh to learn and
University Amherst communities to help
you build this out and this becomes a
real example that you can take with you
to Showcase your skills your knowledge
and really position you for either
career growth in the organization you're
in right now or open up some doors into
other organizations and industries you
might want to pursue
okay
um I'm gonna need to reset
uh
I will be right back okay okay well
while um
Stewart's resetting a few things you
might want to consider notice there's a
a couple of uh questions getting posted
into the chat looks like we also uh have
Kalia who's uh putting a lot of
information in here about the program uh
don't forget we do have an option for
you to submit more formal q a style
questions so if you see your question
perhaps is getting a little lost with
all the texts that's going on uh take
the time to kind of post that
a few things that I do see is that uh
um if you already have a PMP
um and it looks like some
Judah saying what is what if you already
have your PMP like I have to be honest
I'm one of the contributors also well
done okay so it sounds like you'll be a
lot of strong background in this domain
already so that's gonna definitely help
that's going to position you to kind of
get full advantage
for what this program offers
um and really it's about
about strengthening your skills and
these other
areas so it should be good fit for that
yeah I apologize for that we sometimes
have a
program included and then and uh want to
take those
um which include
um training for
PMI
um lean Six Sigma Green Belt
um program management professional from
the PMI um
and the customer-centric digital
transformation so uh Ryan you can talk a
little bit about the certifications
right yeah absolutely so
all these certifications managed and
facilitated by the project management
Institute so this is part of the reason
this is such a globally recognized set
of certifications the PMP uh think of
this is sort of the uh you know the the
foundation for all things project
management really important
certification to get so everything
you're gonna learn in this program is
going to position you to successfully
pass that exam and it's a pretty
comprehensive and frankly pretty demand
exam so we
want to make sure all the learners
uh are comfortable going into
split so they can be successful
these other ones
which are also part of the pmo
my family
wrist man
professional you know
a lot of these uh very large
initiatives me
a specialized
risk management
uh skill sets so you get a chance
to get those certs your
program management professional
foreign
in the process itself speaking of
transformations
so um can you describe how people use
these different uh
tools and platforms within within the
program absolutely so
um you know there's there's a lot going
on in the slide uh
each one of these different icons
represent important Frameworks and
Concepts that you are going to learn so
you can apply them effectively to manage
large-scale projects so demayak which is
a part of sort of the total quality
domain is focused on how do we Define
and measure and analyze and improve and
control our processes and as a project
manager that's going to be really
important for you okay the whole life
cycle project management involves us
understand our requirements based on
those requirements to do some design
some analysis some development some
testing so this process is really
important we see agile agile is all
about how do we find ways to do this
more effectively more efficiently
bringing people and teams together so
they can interact record every progress
we've got the project management body of
knowledge so this is sort of think of
this as the project managers uh you know
guide to all the things that need to
occur to successfully deliver projects
so it's a great way reference that the
PMI is built out over 20 plus years
we've got lean six Sega and I think I
might have mentioned to you that that's
sort of really emphasizing how to become
more efficient how do we drive waste out
of the work so we're not waiting for
things we're not reaching information
we're making sure that we're being
really efficient and then the other side
are our tools so minitab is a
statistical analysis tool this could be
really important for us to understand
how our processes working uh jira many
of you probably come across jira jira is
a great work management tool that helps
agile delivery practices
of course Microsoft Office such an
important meat tool for us to present
information analyze it with Excel you
know
share progress updates through tools
like Microsoft PowerPoint and then we
talked a little bit about Microsoft
Project how that's going to help us
really organize all the work that our
projects need to deliver and and that's
just the tip of the iceberg there's more
products and tools you'll get exposed to
throughout the program
right and when when you say exposed to
it's it's a matter of actually using
them in each of these component courses
of the of the program right I mean
absolutely yeah you're going to be able
to not just list these as buzzwords on
your resume at the end but you're going
to be able to provide examples of
your skills when asked you'll be able to
prove that you've got the skills you
need to do so that's a great advantage
of the program
um the Capstone project we've mentioned
several times and that's Brian said
last module of the program
essentially
serves as a kind of final exam and it's
about a three to four week uh effort
right right yeah it's a it's a fair
amount of work but it really ties
everything you've been learning together
uh to Showcase in this final project
that this Capstone initiative yeah you
pick a
challenge that is an industry based real
world type problem in you then Build
Your solution to it
which is evaluated for your uh
final
certificate but also is something that
you can
Brian said take with you and show to
people about this is the way they
you apply your project management skills
in a real world situation so
this is a really valuable tool and at
this point I'm going to ask Brian to
share his screen and take us through a
live tour of the learning environment
sure thing let me do that stop sharing
from my side of your side okay
yeah can you see my screen okay
yes okay so yeah one of the things that
I think really makes this program Stand
Out relative to other offerings you
might find in the market is this
learning management system this LMS that
sent to learn has been uh building and
enhancing and refining over uh many many
years here and it becomes a really
powerful tool to address one of the
bigger challenges a lot of people find
at this point in their careers you know
you're actively working you know many of
you have five plus years of experience
so you've got a full-time job and most
of us have responsibilities outside of
work so this idea of saying oh and in
addition now invests all this time and
energy into learning these new skills
and and
engaging in a program like this can be
really challenging so the LMS is really
powerful it gives it gives you a
platform that you can access really from
anywhere and I think you heard uh
Stewart mentioned earlier this is you
can just send this work on your your
lunch hours at the office coffee breaks
you might have you can access this
through your mobile device your laptop
your tablet whatever it might be so that
part makes it really powerful because it
enables you to learn in a variety of
different settings and it fits your
schedule which is going to be really
important at this point in your careers
so once you log in you get the list of
courses so we've already talked a little
bit about these uh courses you scroll
down you can see these little cards
these tiles you can see the types of
formats that are available some of these
are they're all self-learning enabled
but in addition you can participate in
live classes
the live classes are a great complement
to the self-learning
um a lot of people you know prefer to
kind of learn on their own but when they
have times where maybe they want an
instructor to talk through a particular
topic or they want to
um maybe engage and ask a few questions
the live learning becomes really
powerful so let's just click on a few of
these give you a better flavor for what
that experience is
um by the way the first time uh you you
log in you'll see you're going to get
some little wizard that's going to guide
you through the different features and
functions of the Tool uh here's
reminding us hey you can do an
assessment at the end of your projects
and take some tests that you can
evaluate your learning there's a
community you can be part of so you're
not doing this in isolation that's a
really important part of this is that
you are part of a cohort that's coming
in you're all going to learn and
progress together uh I was very uh
impressed with sort of the global reach
of our participants today and I think
that makes a learning experience even
more impactful because you're connecting
with people from around the world
they're all bringing their own
experiences and perspectives together
you're going to learn and benefit from
that
so once we um get to here you'll see
that there's a very um highly uh
produced uh videos that will help you
with your self-learning and you can
follow that along you can pause it at
any point you can leave and come back to
it whenever you want you can see that
there's
also live classes that are available now
of course right now these have not been
uh set up yet for uh this particular
cohort but when you start the program
you'll see a collection of different
classes available that you can join and
you can join any class you want you can
retake a class if you felt that you
wanted to you know learn some of the
ideas and Concepts again how we want to
approach it is really up to you
um we also have that assessment so
notice we've got some practice
assessments here this PMP one in
particular is uh it's quite a
challenging exam and frankly my guidance
would be if you are preparing for this
is to take at least
three to four of these full-length
practice exams and just test your
knowledge and notice that when you click
on this you will um you have to in fact
go through the classes and I think my
instructor level view is one that's uh a
little limited right now because the
program hasn't started but it will time
you so you'll get a sense of how long
it's taking to complete the questions
it'll also give you feedback on which
questions you answered correctly which
ones you might want to go back spend a
little more time understanding the
concepts
so that's the project management
professional we also have the scrum
master class all these use the same
general format sometimes uh similar's
frequently updating content to make it
very Uh current and reflective sort of
new ideas Concepts Etc so you can kind
of go back to that it's uh
and we'll just click on this I'll just
resume the learning right now to avoid
doing the update uh but in the same
format notice that we've got the same
layout same look and feel so it should
be very easy for you to navigate from
one course to the next
um same structure with live class
opportunities assessments and then look
at this we've gone to reference
materials we've got case studies that
you can look to and kind of understand
how to apply these practices in a real
world setting you've got this course
slides themselves which you can download
and maybe you're in a setting that
doesn't have internet access that's okay
you can look at the course slides on
your device so lots of different ways in
which you can support your learning
um
we think we also heard that there are
different
um
electives that we can spend time on okay
you can see these here so there's a wide
range of electives available everything
from devops that developmental
operations certification that program
management one that I mentioned look
business analytics with Excel a lot of
project managers have to be quite
comfortable and familiar with business
analytics so lots of additional elective
options you have available and you can
continue to track your progress
throughout the whole learning management
system
Stuart what else did I anything else you
think we need to cover
um I think you covered most of it
while I was looking in the chat did you
talk about the community oh yeah thanks
for bringing it up so uh yeah there is a
a very active community of not just uh
participants in your cohort but also
people like myself your instructors and
other
um classes that are being delivered so
we can click on community here I've got
it right up here so you'll come to the
simply learned Community notice they've
already created a forum for the
postgraduate program project management
obviously not a lot happening here right
now uh but when the program starts
you'll see a lot of activity starting to
appear here so if you've got a question
any time of the day you can pop it into
this forum and others will respond to
your instructors monitor this simply
learn monitors so you get lots of
support as you're working through any of
the content material
appreciate that and
let's move on then
so I'm going to take back screen sharing
okay
and
we'll move on to
the latter part of our presentation here
we want to welcome the folks who joined
us through Linkedin live we were having
problems getting that started so if you
would like to get a copy of this
recording please contact us at uh
the email address will share so ask us
at simplylearn.net if you are on one of
the streaming services that came in late
and would like to get a link to this
recording
contact us that way let's mention the
program advisor
I'm John Welch from uh University of uh
Massachusetts Amherst and he is the
Senior Pro Vice Provost for lifelong
learning so he oversees all of their
um
professional education programs
including this one which
delivered as I mentioned by simply learn
on our digital platform the Brian just
showed you
um and
it's responsible for making sure that
the content of the new program the
curriculum and all the components are up
to the standard of
University of Massachusetts and Amherst
in the Eisenberg School of Management
so
this is a program from them delivered by
us at simply
talk about some of the success stories
of people that have taken our programs
before and uh
have all
successfully completed the program and
gotten a career advancement out of the
process
we would hope that you'd be able to
contribute your own success stories if
you take this program so these are
available on our
website we'll be sharing that link later
but we have a number of successful
Learners who've completed the program
and one of the
aspects that helps you succeed is the
career assist service
so the job assist program is available
specifically in the
countries of India and then in U.S
Canada
um unfortunately we don't offer it in
other countries around the world but if
you are a Learner in India or you're a
Learner in the US we have
um programs in India it's with IIM jobs
in the US it's with Talent Inc
to provide you a specific
job search and job search prep tools
that extend for six months after you
earn your certificate through the
program
we also offer a series of webinars that
simply learn puts on and of course the
experience that you gain in the program
with your projects including the
Capstone project so let's
let's talk about specifically what you
get through IIM jobs in India or
talenting North America and you get
access to the respective job portals
from those organizations which give you
access to certain exclusive job listings
but also give you a way to apply to
those jobs that's uh discrete that's
private and confidential so that um
your job search remains
your own business rather than anyone
else's
um that again extends for six months
after the beginning or the certification
um
then you also receive a couple of other
services that I think are
equally important if not more so which
resume review and rewrite service
and the one-on-one interview prep you
get resumes today when you submit those
for a job search
they don't go to a human being until
they've gone through an automated
tracking system
passed by an AI bot which manages the
content of your resume against the job
description
and
your challenge is to write your resume
in such a way that the AI bot will
filter you in rather than filtering out
which is a specific set of resume
writing skills
but then after that process it does go
to you goes onto their desktop or onto
their screen
and so the resume still has to be
appealing to the eye
and catch the attention of the
recruiters and managers who are going to
see it so
balancing those two objectives of a
resume that's AI friendly and a resume
that is tension grabbing that's an art
form that these organizations will help
you with with the professional writers
who will help you rewrite your resume in
the two rounds so
um
the one-on-one interview prep
is similarly important for the same kind
of reason you'd have to go through a lot
of different
kinds of interviews as you approach a
job search or a promotion and they may
start with a phone screen with a
recruiter or an HR rep
then move on to
the technical
interview that verifies your skill set
people usually people who will be on
your team or your immediate supervisor
will ask questions about your abilities
and your skills and this is where
proving your skills becomes important
and then you'll have another set of
interviews that we'll talk about your
ability to work as part of a team
and your fit with the culture of the
organization
so each of those types of interviews has
a different flavor and your ability to
do one-on-one live prep with interview
preparers
so you'll manage for you in this program
so these are not job guarantee or job
placement Services these are tools that
you used to conduct your job search and
help you be more effective at it
ended successfully so
we'll talk about the expert webinars
simply on runs a webinar series we bring
in experts from industry Brian has done
some of these in the past where we do an
overview of the
particular
sector domain you might be in or
or we would bring a particular skill and
do a mini lesson on a particular skill
set we do career management career care
and feeding webinars about how to do a
job search or how to in the kinds of
soft skills that you'll need in order to
be more successful in your career or how
to do career planning and look
career trajectory in a holistic way so
these are all free webinars these are
done as I mentioned weekly and have
access to them on a lifelong basis
and we've talked about
project portfolio these are some of the
Capstone
options
so
you can for example
help look at an organization's hyper
growth that would be something like zoom
and how it
tremendously grew during the pandemic
because of the demand for its service or
you could look at a blockchain system
that has to be done for uh
Healthcare Pharmacy patient so all these
different areas and different domains
you get to pick the one that appeals to
you most
and then do your project over the three
to four weeks
then you end up with
final result that you can showcase to
Future employers you can use to
demonstrate your skills take people
through and show them the details of how
you used the different tools and
Platforms in order to solve different
aspects of each of these problems so
this is uh Again part of your
Career Development and assistance with
your job search
now I'm going to talk about the program
fees if you are in India it is uh 97
9999 rupee
um
the financing for that would be zero
interest financing as low as 8 167 a
month
if you're in the U.S it's
2299 2299
which can be financed out at low
interest uh
203 a month
if you are elsewhere in the world you
want to check with ask us at
simplylearn.net to find out your local
pricing
which would
usually be denominated in US dollars but
it'll be similar to these and
um
at this point based on everything that
Brian and I have shared with you
are you interested
in enrolling in the program so this is
level of Interest
uh Mickey commitment right now but you
are telling us if this is something
you'd like to pursue
I'm going to leave this open for about
15 seconds as
a yes or no question
I'll leave it open for another
five
four
three
two one
in the poll share the results
three quarters of our audience uh
indicated yes you are interested in
Rolling which is fantastic
so let's go into
[Music]
the particular steps you follow for that
very straightforward you need to email
us at ask us at simplylearn.net that is
something I will put into the chat right
now
a moment as I
copy that over and move it
oh why am I having a difficulty with
that
here we go
I'll just for the delays I get this
copied over
here we go
so for your convenience I put into the
chat the email address here although
it's very straightforward ask us
simplylearn.net
once you email us we will ask you for
certain facts we'll ask you verify your
job consider your work history
Brian
I have another quick zoom problem so
hold on for just a second
sure and uh as uh Stewart's addressing
that I have been uh trying to uh skim
through questions that are in the chat
and responding to uh to some of the
questions there uh also see people are
using the Q a area that's a little
easier to see some of these questions so
we would encourage you if you got to
post your questions in there and when we
get a little closer to the end I think
we'll have some time to dig into a few
of those questions
okay I am back but uh let me re-share my
screen here
um
one of those things when we have
uh things going more than one thing
going on
with the uh
Zoom
so
again as I mentioned we will evaluate
your application we'll ask you for your
work history we'll ask you for uh
verification of your bachelor's degree
and we'll ask you some questions about
your interest level in project
management and
um your commitment and your you want to
make sure that you're willing to put in
the six months of effort to succeed in
the program because it's
our best interest and your best interest
to make sure that uh you have that
commitment going in so that you'll end
up with a successful and
pleasant experience and then we'll send
you an admission offer so the next
cohort starts
in April with classes on the 24th and
the orientation for that is 30th March
to um
we do these cohorts pretty much monthly
but you can get started in this one
pretty quickly so
let's again Ask a quick poll question
that's a quick pull question is
for those of you who said you are
interested
75 percent
how soon would you like to to get
involved
I'll leave this against
straightforward question so we'll leave
this open for just another 10 seconds
and I'll close the poll five
four
three
two one
we'll share the results
so between the people who want to start
in the April classes or the ones who
want to start maybe May or June that
would be about 40 percent of our
audience
and the rest of you um
please contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net and then we'll we'll be
able to answer any questions you might
have about the program and we'll also be
able to keep you informed about future
cohorts
so with that
we've reached the Q a I will stop
sharing the screen so that you don't
have to look at the slide
and
go into some of the questions that we
have
from
uh the audience hold on just a second
yes
pulling up some of the questions I got
out of the chat
um James asked whether
attending live classes is mandatory and
it depends on the course but you do have
to
of course will tell you how many of the
live classes you must attend in order to
be able to complete that course
successfully of those different modules
in the course you do have to right Brian
yeah exactly right so you've got some
flexibility there some of them are gonna
you'll get a lot of benefit pretending
the live sessions
um but you'll still have access to all
the same content that you can absorb in
whatever way is that most convenient for
you
recognizing that
things happen in people's lives and you
can't always be there for every single
class you do have the option to review
the class material from a recording so
if you are on track to complete all your
live classes and something comes up you
can't be there on a particular weekend
to rest assured you'll be able to catch
up
but support communities that Muhammad
asks question is it from Simply learning
from the University and the combination
of both similar instructors and your
classmates are part of the
Community you also get a chance to ask
some of the um
books from the University questions and
um
we have a simply learned run 24x7 help
desk that will answer questions if you
raise a support ticket about the
platform itself or have particular
content related question
that
needs a
faster turnaround than the community
will give you so
but rest assured you have the ability to
ask those questions
at any time
such and ask a question is
it was a one-word question construction
which I assume means how does project
management play in the construction
field is this program good for people
who are in that industry
Brian can you talk about that
yeah absolutely in fact um
a lot of the the construction industry
relies heavily on the project management
uh body knowledge and the discipline of
project management itself so
um much of what you're going to be
learning in these courses are going to
apply very directly to that space and
and just to kind of you know offer a
little bit of perspective on agile so
agile lends itself very well to the
digital domains a lot of organizations
thinking that transition to digital
Transformations agile fits very well in
that space so it is a great pairing you
know more conventional traditional
project management at larger scale
Industries like construction use uh
complements very nicely to Agile
practices that are applied in more
digital settings
cool
um excuse me as I move in here
I have to look around my webcam for a
second
um
so we had a question from uh Neha who
asked it's the experience
The Five-Year experience requirement has
to be at a specific industry can it be
in any corporate work experience uh Neha
has been a corporate lawyer for nine
years
um yeah
lawyers and Law Offices definitely need
to use project management skills
especially if you're repairing any type
of a case uh
trial or for settlement or for Pursuit
um you understand all the different
pieces that have to go into that right
Brian is
yeah for sure and in fact a large a lot
of large legal organizations do have
pretty established project management uh
functions because there's a lot of
projects that these organizations need
both to enable the lawyers and these
complex court cases uh they're pursuing
um many of you have probably been
hearing a lot about you know these
advances in artificial intelligence and
chat GPT uh well the legal profession is
very eager to harness those new
technologies and project management is
going to be a really important way in
which those get implemented in these
organizations so a lot of exciting work
going on in that space
thank you uh thank you Nanny asks of a
BBA background uh with the experience of
more than five years
um
will I need an experience certificate we
will be asking for verification of your
of your work history so you'll be able
to be able to
provide some evidence of that and then
um
he ba background student if you haven't
got your bachelor's degree but you plan
to get it awarded uh during the next six
months you'll be able to
pursue this program but we do we do
require that you have your bachelor's
degree before you get your certificate
um discounts available contact us at ask
us at simplylearn.net find out if there
are discount offers currently available
they haven't informed me of one but
um
of course let me look down as I go
through the Q a here
uh somebody had an audio problem we will
send out a email with a link to this
recording so hopefully you'll be able to
review anything you missed
um Emi option is available
and
Sonic asked a question for you Brian
which is better PMP or Six Sigma for
project manager uh and especially in the
uh you're on mute especially managing uh
an I.T department for a company
yeah that's a great question so um a
couple things about that project
management the BMP is really going to
focus on how do you manage a project
effectively you know how do you develop
a schedule to support
um a delivery day how do you organize
your budget bring people in manage risks
and issues whereas leads at Sigma is
going to focus more on the processes
that you're using and making sure those
are efficient that you're not you know
waiting too much that there's no waste
in your system so the two pair very
nicely which is why I simply learn and
University of Massachusetts Amherst have
have seen that hey we need to teach both
these Concepts and they complement each
other very well and within an I.T
setting I think you're probably going to
find the project management skill set
it's going to be really important for
you to implement new systems or
enhancements uh to your existing systems
and the lean six signal part is going to
help make sure you're efficient
supporting your customers and making
sure that they're getting the uh the
services that they need
Neelam asks if PMP is useful only for
engineers
well it's uh it's a very extensible uh
certification so much much more than
just Engineers Engineers can get a lot
of value from this uh I think I
mentioned I work for many many large oil
and gas companies that are very
engineering Centric they use PMP
extensively but I also work in
healthcare and Healthcare uses these
same practices as well as high tech so
in fact very extensible I couldn't say
that any one particular industry or
profession uses it more than another
these are a set of practices that are
very extensible across all Industries
and professions
uh is there any way we can complete the
course faster than six months if we want
to and generally speaking Santosh uh
not really because this course is
structured in a way that you need to
take the sequence of classes in the set
sequence and with the live class
schedule you can't really accelerate
that because those are held on a fixed
calendar schedule so
um that's it's
sir this is not a self-study program
where you do it completely on your own
pace this is a program where you're in a
cohort and there's advantages for having
other students in that same cohort that
you can work with
um
so is the finance option automatically
available or do you have to apply you do
have to apply it is not completely
automatic but it's very straightforward
and in the organizations we use for
financing are
if you're if you're qualified to do the
uh program
you're generally qualified to receive
the financing but you do have there is
an application
um
will we be having handouts and videos of
the classes we go on
Ryan yeah people about that absolutely
so
um you might remember when I was kind of
showing the LMS there was a section that
included all sorts of good reference
material but all the course lines will
be available there's also case studies
you'll have access to
reference sheets that make some of this
learning a little bit more condensed and
you've got a little kind of cheat sheet
you can use particularly when you're
preparing for some certification exams
so the short answer is absolutely you'll
get lots of opportunity to kind of print
out any handouts you need
can owning your own business for 10
years count as project management